welcome to this video playing our roux
paris from spain i have not played this
guy before so may try the Kalashnikov
variation I really have forgotten the
theory him I think I I had some idea
here with not playing b5 ya know it sir
it's a smashing cough again ok and then
player to play the swash take over I
have some basic knowledge that at least
Bishop g7 or f5 both paso will see form
yeah this is one of those gambit loud do
we or do you play before in this
position see form
hmm
I can't remember I can't remember I have
played the specially call for years ago
so I I have some idea but it's not like
I remember everything ok I think the
main line is Bishop d3 or c3 c4 is
certainly also plata but i couldn't
remember ok it's just ignoring it ok I
imagine just take it him huh interesting
I can give this check now triac irritate
him or I mean queen trade okay Allah he
wants he does not object to them to the
Queen trade okay check check let's see
before this one move pushing the night
back to be one orbit should be 60
playing it a bit more dynamic way or f5
even okay let's play a bit more dynamic
end of their five I interesting Salim
scrapping grabbing the Queen side well I
take the center interesting okay just
King e7 here to cover it i guess night
c4 into this interesting now but i can
just take it yeah yeah everything else
fails i can just take me five of course
what I want to do here I want to get in
the full center would be a fantastic
with d5 so something like bishop is six
and d5 maybe just do that this should be
six and d5 next I don't he can take on a
six I don't care i want i want this
fantastic sent I'm 25 I'm one pawn down
but i'm i'm ready to push the whole
center forward I be sure to 60 maybe I
should have reacted to this
for one for one moment that's not good
okay I don't want to give up the deep
bond I rather give up the exchange the
spawn zone or something yeah I really
should take the rook it is not
interesting
not sure how to play it exactly
many many ways to to go maybe III was
Miss charge hmm that's very very tough
position to play
see refuses to change my book
check
time warner let's let's push him I can
take a fall what this is I totally
overlooked that I'm not sure if this is
so dangerous maybe it is but check
nice taking you for unfortunately
it should be for e2
is there no way to do anything here so
strating check and why do I go check
this diagonal this does not make any
sense check yeah it's just playing on
time this is why i always want increment
black snow totally winning of course he
was winning and now I'm just promoting
the pawns but it's not doesn't matter
because he will win on time
check check check check black for fits
on time yes maiden to know yeah but this
is it's pointless and it's an old story
if you fall behind so far the clock they
can play all kinds of rubbish and and
still win this was an interesting game I
play I tried to play it very
aggressively and it was I think okay for
the most part maybe this son this
exchange sacrifice was a bit was a bit
much the main problem was that I had I
hadn't really paid attention to Bishop
c6 i am here instead of this quick f5 I
just need to to play a good move and I'm
in excellent shape rucca h g8 is given
by the comp with an almost decisive edge
for black which is no surprise I mean if
you look at this I have a fantastic
center with potential to to get passed
pawns I have two bishops and he has
misplaced pieces that's not how a six is
not misplaced wrong marker here but
those pieces don't coordinate well
something like this is given by the comb
a few of you look at this type of
position does for example this is simply
a catastrophe I'm a pawn down but if you
consider rugae three you threatened a
compass on minus four just to put it
into perspective and I've got f-4e for
Bishop g7 d3 coming this is just a
steamroller I really overlooked Bishop
c6 and here are the sister computer is
giving even this as a big as a
match for black mark begich sorry but 0
0 but bought one porno yeah whatever I
mean it's clear that black has a very
good compensation and I but d4 move I'm
sorry III is probably the wrong with him
it's not a game look at a seven
interesting move very interesting the
ideas even bishop CA a-- or maybe you
would be eight and then give it back
take the exchange on be some this is one
important point with a great physician
this is minus 2 we are it's not like
it's just compensation it's just
fantastic f4 III it's a big steamroller
and the center typical sveshnikov star
yeah and here here I'm worse I really am
well just zero point something by the
camp but it felt it felt very very
difficult the points are not mobile
anymore I what I try to stay up some
trouble but it didn't really this is
really no no threat so I need check
check okay well here white is totally
winning of joy played this is a mystery
to me I mean after this widest white is
just in terrible shape against the pawns
compass just on minus one which I don't
understand really am and no matter just
promoting here how does he stop it like
King he played this okay after this I'm
winning with this move okay that's clear
but this okay this still is just minus
one yeah well he played rook t5 when I
had five seconds sir so on he could just
play would be fine or anything and and
Whitney
okay thanks for watching